avons pu joindre notre envoyé spécial à
odessa gwendoline de bono bonjour
gwendoline merci d'être en direct avec
nos cieux sur france 24
vous vous trouvez sur la plage on le
voit derrière vous cette ville portuaire
extrêmement importante pour pour
l'ukraine cette ville portuaire qui se
trouve au bord de la mer noire là bas
les habitants se se prépare à une
offensive russe
oui absolument et vous le voyez derrière
moi les gens qui collectent le faible
pour le mettre dans les sacs qui
serviront à faire les checkpoint à
construire des barricades et bien ce
sont des habitants de la ville ce sont
des volontaires on a rencontré par
exemple un chanteur de l'opéra où il a
rencontré un pianiste on a rencontré un
prof de maths on a rencontré à
l'étudiant donc c'est vrai qu'ici on
voit un petit peu et bien toutes les
couches de la société tout dessin venir
se mobilisent et venir faire quelque
chose et c'est vrai que l'un d'entre
nous disait tout à l'heure et j'ai
rarement vu une unité comme ça dans la
ville d'odessa alors il ya aussi ont des
gens qui viennent parce que mentalement
nous disent ils ça leur fait du bien de
faire quelque chose ensemble de ne pas
rester sur internet à regarder les
nouvelles à regarder l'avancé russe et
c'est vrai qu'il y a aussi sa dent dans
ces gens qui viennent se mobiliser alors
là effectivement nous sommes sur la
plage ici c'est une plage où l'on
travaille à collecter le sable mais sur
d'autres plages sur d'autres endroits de
la côte d'autres défense se prépare à on
sait que plusieurs autres plages ont par
exemple été miné que des mines antichars
ont été posés pour prévenir une invasion
russe par la mère d'un des marins nous
disait tout à l'heure si les seuils à
d'attaqué par la côte et bien ils
finiront au fond de l'eau donc on voit
toujours cette détermination
ukrainienne et puis cette ville d'odessa
qui se mobilisent aussi pour les autres
villes pour le front le plus proche en
l'occurrence la ville de micola yves à
100 km de là là on voit des habitants
venir porter des colis alimentaires
venir porter toutes sortes de choses
hein dans des camions qui vont aller
vers cette ville où pour l'instant se
situe le front se situe l'avancé russe
au sud mais les ukrainiens tiennent
toujours est cette ville de micola iv
pour l'instant dans cette ville eh bien
les forces russes peine tu as avancé que
cette ville stratégique puisqu'elle leur
permettrait de couper la route entre
desai kiev merci beaucoup gwendoline de
bono en direct d'odessa où on le voit
les habitants se prépare à une offensive
russe sur la place